el presidente de ecuador lenín moreno ha
emitido nuevamente el estado de sección
y toque de queda desde el 2 de abril que
se extenderá por 30 días en el país
andino
ecuador regresa al estado de sección
luego que su sistema sanitario se
encuentra colapsado en algunos casos
atendiendo al 145 por ciento y con
pacientes en el piso las medidas
responden ante las alerta de calamidad
pública que existe en ocho provincias
del país a partir del viernes 2 de abril
se aplicarán toques de queda desde las 8
de la noche hasta las 5 de la mañana se
suspende la jornada laboral presencial
en el sector público se prohíben los
eventos de concentraciones de tipo
religioso a propósito de la semana santa
se suspende las clases presenciales se
restringe la movilidad vehicular
mientras que el transporte público de
sectores estratégicos se mantienen con
ciertas autorizaciones para la menta
defensoría del pueblo exhorta el
ejecutivo nacional a volver al semáforo
rojo en todo el país hasta disminuir la
demanda hospitalaria el gobierno
nacional aseguró que las nuevas medidas
no afectarán en las elecciones generales
a realizarse en el país andino el 11 de
abril